Here's another approach to improving the latency
of our adder, this time focusing just on the
carry logic.
Early on in the course, we learned that by
going from a chain of logic gates to a tree
of logic gates, we could go from a linear
latency to a logarithmic latency.
Let's try to do that here.
We'll start by rewriting the equations for
the carry-out from the full adder module.
The final form of the rewritten equation has
two terms.
The G, or generate, term is true when the
inputs will cause the module to generate a
carry-out right away, without having to wait
for the carry-in to arrive.
The P, or propagate, term is true if the module
will generate a carry-out only if there's
a carry-in.
So there only two ways to get a carry-out
from the module: it's either generated by
the current module or the carry-in is propagated
from the previous module.
Actually, it's usual to change the logic for
the P term from "A OR B" to "A XOR B".
This doesn't change the truth table for the
carry-out but will allow us to express the
sum output as "P XOR carry-in".
Here's the schematic for the reorganized full
adder module.
The little sum-of-products circuit for the
carry-out can be implemented using 3 2-input
NAND gates, which is a bit more compact than
the implementation for the three product terms
we suggested in Lab 2.
Time to update your full adder circuit!
Now consider two adjacent adder modules in
a larger adder circuit:
we'll use the label H to refer to the high-order
module and the label L to refer to the low-order
module.
We can use the generate and propagate information
from each of the modules to develop equations
for the carry-out from the pair of modules
treated as a single block.
We'll generate a carry-out from the block
when a carry-out is generated by the H module,
or when a carry-out is generated by the L
module and propagated by the H module.
And we'll propagate the carry-in through the
block only if the L module propagates its
carry-in to the intermediate carry-out and
H module propagates that to the final carry-out.
So we have two simple equations requiring
only a couple of logic gates to implement.
Let's use these equations to build a generate-propagate
(GP) module and hook it to the H and L modules
as shown.
The G and P outputs of the GP module tell
us under what conditions we'll get a carry-out
from the two individual modules treated as
a single, larger block.
We can use additional layers of GP modules
to build a tree of logic that computes the
generate and propagate logic for adders with
any number of inputs.
For an adder with N inputs, the tree will
contain a total of N-1 GP modules and have
a latency that's order log(N).
In the next step, we'll see how to use the
generate and propagate information to quickly
compute the carry-in for each of the original
full adder modules.
Once we're given the carry-in C_0 for the
low-order bit, we can hierarchically compute
the carry-in for each full adder module.
Given the carry-in to a block of adders, we
simply pass it along as the carry-in to the
low-half of the block.
The carry-in for the high-half of the block
is computed the using the generate and propagate
information from the low-half of the block.
We can use these equations to build a C module
and arrange the C modules in a tree as shown
to use the C_0 carry-in to hierarchically
compute the carry-in to each layer of successively
smaller blocks, until we finally reach the
full adder modules.
For example, these equations show how C4 is
computed from C0, and C6 is computed from
C4.
Again the total propagation delay from the
arrival of the C_0 input to the carry-ins
for each full adder is order log(N).
Notice that the G_L and P_L inputs to a particular
C module are the same as two of the inputs
to the GP module in the same position in the
GP tree.
We can combine the GP module and C module
to form a single carry-lookahead module that
passes generate and propagate information
up the tree and carry-in information down
the tree.
The schematic at the top shows how to wire
up the tree of carry-lookahead modules.
And now we get to the payoff for all this
hard work!
The combined propagation delay to hierarchically
compute the generate and propagate information
on the way up and the carry-in information
on the way down is order log(N),
which is then the latency for the entire adder
since computing the sum outputs only takes
one additional XOR delay.
This is a considerable improvement over the
order N latency of the ripple-carry adder.
A final design note: we no longer need the
carry-out circuitry in the full adder module,
so it can be removed.
Variations on this generate-propagate strategy
form the basis for the fastest-known adder
circuits.
If you'd like to learn more, look up "Kogge-Stone
to select the right answers.
So the overall latency
of the carry-select adder
is order log(N).
Note that log2(N)
and log(N) only
differ by a constant
factor, so we
ignore the base of the
log in order-of notation.
The carry-select adder shows a
clear performance-size tradeoff
available to the designer.
Since adders play a big role
in many digital systems,
here’s a more carefully
engineered version of a 32-bit
carry-select adder.
You could try this
in your ALU design!
The size of the
adder blocks has been
chosen so that the trial
sums and the carry-in
from the previous stage
arrive at the carry-select MUX
at approximately the same time.
Note that since the select
signal for the MUXes is heavily
loaded we’ve included a buffer
to make the select signal
transitions faster.
This carry-select adder is about
two-and-a-half times faster
than a 32-bit ripple-carry
adder at the cost of about twice
as much circuitry.
A great design to remember
when you’re looking to double
the speed of your ALU!